franchement, nous avons gagné cette élection,
je suis ici pour vous dire ce soir que nous pensons que
nous sommes sur la bonne voie pour gagner cette élection,
un groupe de personnes très tristes
essaie de priver ce groupe
de personnes de ses droits
et nous ne le tolérerons pas, ce n'est pas mon
ou chez Donald Trump pour déclarer
qui a gagné cette élection, c'est la
décision du peuple américain
mais je suis optimiste quant à ce résultat,
les résultats de ce soir ont été phénoménaux
et nous nous préparons, je veux dire
littéralement, nous étions tous prêts à
sortir et juste  célébrons quelque chose de si
beau, si bon, un tel
vote, un tel succès, les citoyens
de ce pays sont venus
en nombre record, c'est un record,
il n'y a jamais eu quelque chose de pareil
pour soutenir notre incroyable mouvement, nous
pensons
qu'un des réseaux a suggéré que nous  J'ai
déjà gagné l'Arizona mais nous sommes confiants
en l'
Arizona, nous avons beaucoup de vie là-dedans
et quelqu'un a dit que
quelqu'un avait déclaré que c'était une victoire
pour nous et peut-être que ce sera le cas, je veux dire,
c'est possible, nous venons aussi de
l'appeler du Minnesota et nous  nous sommes toujours
dans le jeu en Géorgie même si ce
n'est pas ce à quoi nous nous attendions
nous avons gagné la Géorgie nous avons gagné le Texas nous
gagnons énormément la Pennsylvanie
il va prendre du temps pour compter les
votes nous allons gagner la Pennsylvanie
donc la Floride était un  énorme victoire
ohio un état formidable un grand état j'aime l'
ohio la
caroline du nord grande victoire avec la caroline du nord
nous nous sentons vraiment bien avec le wisconsin
et le michigan
nous gagnons le michigan mais je vais vous dire que
j'ai regardé les chiffres j'ai dit bien
j'ai regardé  J'ai dit wow, c'est beaucoup
et les gens, vous m'avez déjà entendu le dire avant
chaque fois que je sors de la maison de mon grand-père
à Scranton, il criait à Joey,
gardez la foi et ma grand-mère quand
elle rit oh non Joey, propagez-la,
gardez la foi les gars que nous sommes  je vais gagner
ça merci merci merci
nous avons gagné des États et tout d'un coup
j'ai dit ce qui est arrivé à l'élection
c'est fini
et nous avons tous ces annonceurs qui disent
ce qui s'est passé et puis ils ont dit oh
parce que vous savez ce qui s'est passé,
ils savaient qu'ils pouvaient  Je n'ai pas gagné, alors ils ont dit :
allons au tribunal et est-ce que j'ai prédit ce
triton, ai-je dit cela, je
dis cela depuis le jour où j'ai
entendu qu'ils allaient envoyer des dizaines
de millions de bulletins de vote, j'ai dit exactement
parce que soit ils allaient  pour gagner ou
s'ils ne gagnent pas,
ils nous poursuivront en justice c'est une fraude
envers le public américain c'est une
honte
pour notre pays nous nous préparions à
gagner cette élection
franchement nous avons gagné cette élection
donc nous le serons  nous allons à la Cour suprême des États-Unis,
nous voulons que tous les votes s'arrêtent,
nous ne voulons pas qu'ils trouvent des bulletins de vote
à
quatre heures du matin et les ajoutent
à la liste, d'accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est un moment très triste, c'est un moment très triste
pour moi, c'est un moment très triste
et
nous allons gagner et, en ce qui me
concerne, nous en avons déjà un que nous
connaissions en raison du
vote anticipé sans précédent lors d'un vote par correspondance
qui va prendre un certain temps, nous allons  il faut
être patient
jusqu'à ce que le dur travail des votes italiens
soit terminé
et ce n'est pas fini tant que chaque vote n'est pas
compté, chaque bulletin est compté